okay let's go to the 708 area code
caller from 708 who is this hello ok
start so you've got a terrible signal I
didn't hear your name did you say it was
Barry yeah Barry I'm sorry you hear me
better we're not on speaker or Bluetooth
are we oh we're on Bluetooth we are okay
yes let's do let's not do the Bluetooth
thing today please burro bluetooth thank
you okay yeah so I had a question about
education and primary education because
so I work with seventh graders I work
for this AmeriCorps program called City
Year and so I've been working with
seventh graders and I work with a
teacher who has four classes of forty
seventh graders and it's like a terrible
system most students don't turn in their
work and I mean a lot of times on the
show and on cows Hill we talk about
college a lot but we don't talk about
primary education because I think that
the primary education system is spelling
I want to hear some of your thoughts on
that yeah I mean I think it's a system
that is persistently underfunded it pits
factions that should be cooperating
against each other around the failures
of both compensation and negotiating
power and in the end it's it's the kids
that lose so I think the system at its
core has some problems in addition to
that though I do think that there are
curricula issues and we're not I mean
generally before before college people
should be getting education zin critical
thinking in philosophy and in so many
other things that that they're just not
getting so I'm gonna let you go it's
it's crazy in the background but yes
primary education public education I
appreciate the call Thank You Barry and
it's an issue we will we will definitely
deal with again